this was the first movie since we lost
some of the Avengers is it bittersweet
to put this out into the world knowing
that the universe will never be the same
hard for me to tell I haven't had time
to process there yet right I'm still
trying to process being back okay you're
back yeah things are different it's a
new time yeah Jake I am such a fan of
your movies what was the final thing
that made you decide okay I'm ready to
do superhero I'm ready to do cape and
suit all of the fantasy well I love the
first movie of this franchise I mean I I
I thought Jon wants had created a tone
yeah it was funny it was moving and I
really liked that about it and I thought
tom was an incredible spider-man so they
came through the idea I thought oh this
is a new take on yeah kind of what I
would think would usually be a kind of
stale idea and it was totally new and
that inspired me and then yeah then I
was a little worried about the bubble
thing I called it a bubble hat in the
other room and they made fun of me yeah
it was full full face yes not just a
head and so I you know I I had a little
bit of worry about that but um
ultimately also the suit is sick yeah
that was that and then you wore it for
breakfast on your Instagram I just wore
the helmet yeah now did is that your own
did you get to keep it did they lend it
to you for breakfast
that was this down was the helmet that I
practiced and trained in so I did most
of my I like doing a lot of preparation
for roles it's been much on Saturday is
it and um in my right back after I
learned how to fly one of the things I
wanted to make sure it was that could I
fly with the actual fish ball on my head
yeah so I got one from Marvel gave me
the one and I said can nll so I filled
with smoke and I would fly around and it
worked so then I was ready to make the
movie you dope with him Ryan because he
can't block competition no never
please wishes yeah I used to talk to him
a lot until a couple weeks ago but
well this is good so this is a good next
question
so you admitted that you thought the
sexiest Avenger was spider-man yeah he
said spider-man well that's true cute
actually voted for himself in the other
room course he did the greatest
Gyllenhaal of all time I have literally
had no clue I mean three days ago they
asked me if I would sing the greatest
love of all with James Corden and
obviously I said yes immediately and
then they said they were changing the
lyrics to the greatest Gyllenhaal of all
and and that was that that was literally
that we performed it twice I was in over
my head and the truth of the matter is
it's true there are a lot of
Gyllenhaal's but you know maggie is the
best as she has always been and yeah I'm
the younger sibling in right I'm trying
to make it fit
[Music]
[Music]
but at the end
yes amazing according and get to do
almost right amazing um I wanted to get
both of your reactions to Tom doing all
of these stunts and I know you've worked
both work there's so many guys doing a
lot of their own stuff that this kid is
a maniac I mean this stuff that he's
doing is so crazy and we have this great
behind-the-scenes footage of him just
getting pounded with the water and
jumping off the buildings what's it like
to be on set with him the first scene I
did one of the first things I did in the
movie I'm laying on the ground the end
of this battle and he he's supposed to
enter that's what was written but
instead when I got to set there's a
trampoline and the dude jumps on the
scene and I was like I didn't I couldn't
conceive I was like oh me me me me count
it yeah me me me me me count it that
ladies and gentlemen is how you do five
movies in four months you know what I
mean yeah you can't be doing a double
backflip off a trampoline no I couldn't
do that when I was laying yeah I mean
he's like either dancer yes so physical
is amazing um you guys are fabulous
thank you for your singing
[Music]